it was like he was just purposely trying
to humiliate me paris hilton is opening
up about recently surfaced interviews
from her past
and how she was treated by the media it
was just
very cruel and very mean in a new
episode of her podcast
this is paris she recalled her betrayal
in the spotlight in the early 2000s
specifically a 2007 interview with david
letterman
how'd you like being in jail
[Applause]
paris revealed that despite agreeing to
avoid any conversation relating to her
probation violation at the time
letterman ignored the request and
continued to dig into the subject
during her interview so there was not
supposed to be one question
and then he just kept pushing me and
pushing me and
i was just getting so uncomfortable and
i was so upset it was like he was just
purposely trying to humiliate me
and during commercial breaks i would
look at him like please stop doing this
like
you promised me you wouldn't talk about
this it was just very cruel and very
mean
and then after it ended i just looked at
him and i said i am never
coming on the show again like that
you've crossed the line
paris's sister nikki hilton who was also
on the podcast
pointed out that letterman wasn't the
only one to put paris
in an uncomfortable spot you know what
would not happen today
is sarah silverman going on stage
at the mtv awards and making
disgusting vile
perverted statements about
pop stars about people sitting in the
audience
at the 2007 mtv movie awards silverman
took aim at hilton and used her jail
time as material for the opening
monologue of the show
sarah silverman did was so disgusting
and
so cruel and mean just to sit in the
audience with her
just literally just
publicly humiliating me being so mean so
cruel i was sitting there wanting to die
i was trying to hold back my tears so
hard in the podcast paris also shared
that just
hours after sarah silverman's jabs took
place at the mtv movie awards
paris would be turning herself into jail
she goes on to say that while she was
already in a vulnerable state
the jokes at her expense went too far
silverman has since expressed her regret
over her comments revealing in her book
that she felt horribly guilty at the
time
and even wrote a letter to paris hilton
went on in the podcast to acknowledge
that she
along with many other women like herself
were targeted
by the media i would see that with
myself with britney
jessica simpson there was a certain type
of girl where
they would target them in ways that they
would never do to a man
you